auf einmal so sozial sie auch nicht
tschuldigung aber ich hab sehr wichtig
für den aha
und dann laufen alle in verschiedene
richtungen mussten sich was bisschen aus
ein bisschen auf und dann wird sich
getötet was das zeug hält und diesem
zeitpunkt legt man fest wenn man fertig
ausgerüstetes oder wie es geht sofort
los nachweis nicht grace period von drei
minuten oder es gibt auch ohne grace
parierte smart erst mal am anfang in
verschiedene richtungen
wie sagt er so viele möhren kartoffeln
hat er von der pike auf bestimmte
gründung mehr dass ich bin ja der hat
auch daraus eine kutsche fahren ja und
das waren bei der definition und jetzt
hast du neues thema suchen okay ich habe
richtig intelligenz aktie
okay ein sehr interessantes thema was
haltet ihr von der pornoindustrie oder
von prostituierten ps erste eher ernste
frage also ist dann wir die auch ernst
behandeln
und ich finde dass heute auch machen
hast was für dieses wird durch das war
die einzige frage unter tausenden
kommentaren die atomkraft wird von
behindertem us kinostreifen kongo ab da
wo es immer schlechter
voll krass ey bist du kannst du mal
wieder ein gutes video machen wieder
lustig sein kannst du auch mal wieder
ein ordentliches video mal du machst nur
scheiße vorerst beste ich möchte nur
kurz anmerken dass kev genial
intelligent ist weil er hat hier sie
rosen auf sein überweg beim feld gemacht
was man nicht runterfallen schöne wenig
und bewegen sich auch noch und macht
mich ganz kirre weiter in sorge
jetzt fand man hier mit dem thema also
ich nicht also kann ich ganz allein
jedoch dass parteien von den amerikanern
gefangen
danke sagen was die frage was ihr davon
haltet den beruflich oft falsch
angesehen sage ich mir nicht ansehen
ja mittlerweile ist es ja glaub ich
sogar davon die legal also ist legal die
echte berufsbezeichnung einer
prostituierten dass man das echt
anmelden kann und dann war ich etwas so
freiberuflich ist oder so also
steuerlich geregelt und so weit dass
letztlich eine dienstleistung also dass
es ganz nüchtern mit dem recht
betrachtet ja aber es ist eine
dienstleistung eine besondere
qualifikation erfordert wenn du dann ist
es freiberuflich sonst muss ein gewerbe
anmelden höheweg wie schlechte youtube
partner hast du weißt ja muss man sich
leider mit einer auseinandersetzen
hier so 30 wie das bei chen ist diese
folge draußen ist die havel netzwerk
gewechselt oder wie ernsthaft und wer
weiß es noch nicht aber wenn die folge
daraus ist da wie jeder gespannt das was
du mir bitte nach der aufnahme das würde
ich gerne wissen ich glaube da
hingegangen ist schlafen da ich weiß
auch den grund ich bin empört ich bin im
bett von julia alpmann
der grund ist sehr differenziert
einseitig egal wie wir lassen es weil
alle wissen jetzt zeit wo die wir die
folge aufgenommen haben doch modena ist
wenn du jetzt irgendwas sagen dann ist
es natürlich nicht gut aber so will ist
es jetzt auch für mich hat es wegen
fehlender nein bei mir ist einfach nur
ist es dein haus ich brauche eine farbe
oder irgendwas wünschen wieder einfach
nur wow echt schön
das kommt normalerweise ab nein die in
gestaltung deines hauses die lässt
einfach vermutet man seit draußen eine
wunderschöne waren hallo gehst du bitte
durch die tür ist gates sache ja danke
ich hab die einlagen mit einer schaufel
nicht sagen ja komm jetzt mit der
schaufel das auch noch mal das was
erstmals geschlagen haben auch wenn es
auf der ok in ab was willst du sagen
ich wollte nur abschließen um das
nochmal klarzustellen zum thema netzwerk
da da gab es jetzt kein stress oder
irgendwas ist einfach ja keine gründe
aber jetzt keinen so komplett klavier
ihn aber für mich seid ihr jetzt nicht
so irgendwie was was wirklich wichtig
ist sondern das ist halt im hintergrund
notwendig was ist es wir wollen keine
verfolgt doch ich hab vielleicht sogar
welche weiß ich nicht ich habe eine ich
habe eine verschrumpelte hier danke ok
hatte rückte eine textur im den appell
davor nicht und den appell für alle
fragen gibt es jetzt zum download
entgegensehen
ja die gab es ja ewig nicht habe ich
mich gefragt hat er das nicht gemacht
hat er die rechte daran oder hat er
einmal ein bisschen getrickst
aber die rechte nicht getrickst schreibt
sie in die kommentare
danach hatte thema ja und ein netzwerk
steht für mich ein im hintergrund da
muss man sich natürlich gedanken drüber
machen und dass alles bald ein
bildungsprojekt ist aber für mich am
besten wer das netzwerk wenn ich damit
eigentlich nur wenig wie möglich zu tun
habe sondern dass einmal regel und dann
hallo leute moment moment moment moment
das sind meine blumen
und fertig so viel zum thema netzwerk
jetzt schon jetzt allein wie sowieso
nicht gesprochen
das team hatte pornos genau jetzt wieso
ist er jetzt da genau und gab es stress
obwohl es gerade gesagt hast gab's ärger
was passiert den angeblich rausgeworfen
denn die werden was machst du jetzt da
ich hab was hat die was halten damit zu
tun geht ja jetzt auch in sich
bist du da war kommt da ist ja wann
kommt freund mel waggon krank was haben
wir da nur los gibt lesen
vor nicht mal junge einer hand unter
kongos video geschrieben ja dass er voll
behindert das zu 10.000 euro voll
crafter und lena willst du damit die
zudem kommt weil wir und dann hat mir
einer meiner facebook pinnwand gepostet
geschrieben alter ihre news für die
wirklich auch ein fremdwort
dann stand da rauskommen wird einfach
nur lachen
heute sieht man was es bedeutet danke
oder herrlich herrlich herrlich hat es
wird links gefunden
wie heißt es vielleicht des diamanten
weiland kannst du mir kann ich ab sie
den farben gehen
ja habe ich kann die andere spezies
fahren das durch gibt den informanten ja
ok aber das so dass ich auch acht ob sie
den bekomme ich kann ja auch selber fall
wie kriegst keine sorge die danach
direkt wieder die spitze käme ja nein
ich fahre die auch für mich acht fordert
er ist schwachsinn mops der hafen
aschdod verlange ja ich weiß was soll
ich in der sozial- soll ich dir lover
holen sie alles schon mal oben dass du
hier oben ist ob sie den hass oder
willst du runter wobei es sich verdient
eigentlich der hinten war doch ein lover
seht oder ich habe in der höhe wo ich
das abbauen würde auch einen riesigen
laverty dass sich sogar die episch aus
den jetzt mal was ihr über pornos an
gleich gesagt du bist immer gekonnt aus
dem weg gegangen
ich hab' ich habe aber darüber nicht
über prostituierte und das legal und
freiberuflich und alles und dann kamen
mir zu tun und dann kann mit netzwerk-
und da ich bin ich meditieren aber das
ist jetzt bei dem ich bin meine ängste
all nachgeschaut die das interessiert ja
ja ich weiß nicht aber dann bitte gleich
naja ich bin schon wieder total
desorientiert hier weiß nicht wann bist
du dass man nicht ja heute nacht morgen
totschlag was rede ich hier brauchst du
essen ja auf einmal sozial ist ja auch
nicht tschuldigung aber ich habe sehr
wichtig für den aha freue mich jetzt
noch an freund manchmal glaube ich mal
mit dem thema wasser
naja ok statement thema weitermachen ok
deine meinung zum thema skype
die systeme gesellschaft oder er kann
machen was er möchte und ich finde dass
darum wirtschaftszweig ist das bei mir
sind gerade selbstständig tintenfische
gestorben die haben sich einfach
ertränkt beim anblick
da wollen sie nämlich das auch tun aber
ich laufe jetzt im keller wo alter das
den druck den ich mir gemacht hat
perfekt gereicht ahmed jemand
geschrieben ich soll mir mein
schlafzimmer hier dem fels wars ist voll
die quelle de bleiben macht das so
meinte ich habe nur 21 springen von
level zu level zu level ist der endboss
kommt eigentlich erzählen
ist das immer so eine echte mitglied an
denen das nicht sofort mit sie sind
einfach immer so
12 12 123 die rovers erklärten 1 12 so
ich mein haus immer so ein bisschen du
ich glaube wir können direkt im nächsten
weitermachen ich hab mich ja dann sagt
thomas kate jetzt hier hast du weil ich
weiß es nicht ich kann dazu nichts sagen
weil ich damit drin leider keine
erfahrung hat was heißt leider zum glück
zwar ist nicht mit der pornoindustrie
was aber davon und somit was haltet ihr
davon
ich finde das doof das ist das ja
keinerlei erstmal im wolf also ich würde
einfach sagen es ist ein beruf
eigentlich wie jeder andere ist er ist
es ja eine dienstleistung sage ich mal
es heißt genauso wie putzfrau die tut
was für den boxer und putz das
allerdings und die prostituierte tut
halt auch was für den boss nur halt
anders und es ist eine ganz normale
dienstleister sein bedürfnis was gedeckt
werden muss und wenn sie daran geld
verdienen warum nicht nein sind wir
nicht noch 30 uhr so ok die sind wir
schon bestimmt vier mal 13 sind 20
ich musste jetzt nämlich bei mir alle
die jetzt bei mir zu gucken ich lasse es
leuchtet er nervt langkamp die folglich
preisgeld ihr geht aber dahin und
abonniert skates geld ist voll doof
er macht keine minecraft video ist
sowieso nicht der macht auch keine
videos der ist auch nicht die ganze zeit
mit webcam dahinter ja auch mit
cleanskin voll aufwendig und so machte
alles ganz einfach nur scheiße das ist
so als würde ich sorgen und und zu allem
dazu muss jetzt auch noch meine scheiß
aufnahme beenden weil meine wieder
qualifizierte software die ich benutzen
muss weil ich nur so ein blöder youtube
partner bin keine aufnahme länger als
eine stunde machen kann muss ich jetzt
auch noch aufhören und diesem sinne bis
gleich die das liegt daran dass im
falschen netzwerk bis din a3 ja die
falsche programme das liegt einfach am
netzwerk die glocken dass dann die
amazon motto haste wieder aufgenommen da
jetzt eben die frage vorlesen einen
moment jetzt wird es lustig ist muss ich
ja noch speichern dass er das was da ja
das ist jetzt natürlich sehr lustig
haben als alle gelacht
ja richtig guter witz ich jetzt mein
video
naja du hast
20 sekunden wenn es hoch kommt ja das
schaffe ich ja dann ziel schnell
umziehen schnell ausholen das internet
an lassen schnell holt dann kommen sie
wieder
es kann dass es mir erfahren in der zeit
wenn wir wissen wo du wohnst ich war vor
ungefähr südwesten
ach du scheiße da die intelligenz wir
können jetzt mal schlafen gehen habe ich
den eindruck
ich baue jetzt die schlafzimmer wird
richtig apec schwäbisch defekt ich bin
dafür dass wir noch in dieser aufnahme
ob sie denn endlich haben also entweder
du machst das oder ich mache das für
dich luca ja dann macht obama ich habe
bald keinen bock kasten die spitzhacke
da noch irgendwas anderes verschwendet
nein mach ich nicht werden
die zuschauer werden es eben nicht er
ist doch kann sich jetzt obst im haus
warum will eigentlich schlafen
es ist gar nicht macht